so i had heard pete was making one
survivor and i would occasionally see
him in the gym in venice beach
um because we both lived
and he lived in like westward or santa
monica but he liked to work out at
gold's gym
and i would see him in there so we
mentioned that he was
making one survivor and and so i saw him
at like
i don't know some sort of party and he
was
with a friend and i went up to him i was
like what's up with lone survivor man
and he was like you know how there's
like
nfl movie and like you know it's like
you can't play
like a linebacker and it was like i mean
it was like a really like
down down nerd you know what i mean i
was like i was like okay
okay and i just i don't know i just i i
had read the book and i really was moved
by the book
so i wrote pete um a letter being like
you know
how i felt about the project what you
know how i wanted to be a part of it
and my agent was like i don't know he's
he
he just doesn't see for this and i was
like just just
come on and i wrote i think i wrote him
a second letter wow and at one point he
wrote back to me
like show up at gold's
early tomorrow
and i was like what time and he didn't
write back
and i was like oh man this is one of
those like psychological
psychops experiments or something so i
woke up at
4 00 am because gold's gym opened at
like 6 or 5
30 and i was like waiting
at the gym as it opened and this guy tr
goodman who
was the like coach trainer guy shows up
and said
what are you doing here and i was like
oh well pete told me to show up here
early
started laughing he's like come back in
like two hours so i came back
and uh were you pumping by the way were
you pumping up
well or you're just waiting for him like
holy [ __ ] i want what what the hell is
this about
i was just like ready to go you know and
and
basically they put me through this
really hard workout that day
gold's gym um
i i want to separate a really hard
workout for an actor from like
navy seal training it's really not
comparable in any way
at all but for me it was like probably
the hardest i'd ever had to work out
and so they didn't give me the part pete
just said you have to show up here every
day for like
the next few months i'm not giving you
the role
because i genuinely don't know if you
can do it and i'm not gonna disrespect
the seals and this guy's family by
giving an actor that's like
a punk if he can't do it because i was a
little bit
you know i wasn't really in great shape
um
and so it was every day from
six to usually six a.m to like 11. oh
god or 11 30 i would finish and it would
be usually like 90 minutes of
weightlifting
and then it would be two back-to-back
hours of cardio
so i would either do like an hour on the
bike and then an hour jog or like
an hour on the ergometer which is the
arm machine an
hour of that is insane by the way did he
have somebody like watching you and
doing these workouts with you or
did he leave and just assume you were
doing this when i would do
the weights i was training with the
with the workout crew so it would the
guys that i was training with and a
couple of girls
most of the guys were like major league
baseball players or hockey players that
were off season that were like trying to
stay
in top level shape it was it was really
like a performance
weight training camp it's called pro
camp for a reason
in in venice and uh
i definitely got the best shape of my
life and in a certain certain points
it was really hard because every day for
so many hours just on my body and
i was like man this is intense and they
even for what pro camp was they made
sure that what i was doing was always
harder than what everybody else was
doing so
we would be doing like okay let's say we
did 90 minutes of weights
they would be like okay you have to do
jumping jacks between your weight sets
so
while everyone else is waiting at the
machine to do it you have to do the
jumping jacks for like
pop squats or like side step you know it
was stuff like that it would
constantly be like ratcheting it up and
uh
and i just sort of just was super
focused and determined and i really
wanted to be there and i wanted to be in
the film
and i got into really good shape and uh
it was funny i didn't know this at the
time
but apparently tr told peter berg
after the fact that i had trained harder
than anyone he'd ever had other than
chris
chellios who was an nhs stanley cup
champion
hall of famer chicago blackhawks thought
i know shelly [ __ ] best
yeah apparently tr who's like the man he
told pete that he never told me that but
he told pete did you call your agents
and say
so i don't have this role but i have to
work out for the next couple of months
to find out if i
do so you can't really work out a deal
because there's no deal to be had until
pete
gives the word one yeah i mean it was
kind of nerve-wracking in that way
because
if i would if i would like lag
on any of the workouts or if i was doing
um
you know like an interval like long
intervals
or circuits we did a lot of circuits if
i would fall behind
they would be like oh we're going to
tell pete that he's not going to hire me
no they did not
they said that and they were serious
really like hardcore like that
you know and he's like pete has told me
to give an honest assessment and if
you fail at this i will not like you are
not gonna do this
i mean were you pissed were you like did
you kind of laugh it off or were you
like
[ __ ] oh i mean i was frustrated i mean i
remember one day
i was on the leg press and
they just kept stacking more 45s
on the leg press to where like i
genuinely couldn't do it
like it was like it was crazy
and at one point i was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like i stood up and like
chewed these guys out and like walked
off and all the like hockey guys were
like
oh my gosh like this is so but like
i think that they were trying to like
break you
yeah i mean i think that that's or so
he's like all right now that we've got
this anger let's channel it you know i
mean it was like
all this sensei uh you know like karate
kid kind of stuff with with tr
and when was the moment that he called
you but he said you got it and
how'd that happen do you remember that
it might have almost been like a text
message like
you're in or something like that you
know it was like